>>> IN OUR NATNAL LEAD, ADNAN
SYED, WHO WAS SERVING A LIFE
SENTENCE AFTER HWAS CONVICTED
IN 2000 OF MURDERING HIS HIGH
SCHOOL EX-GIRLFRIEND, ADNAN SYED
IS FREE FROM PRISON FOR NOW.
HIS CASE WAS MADE FAMOUS THROUGH
THE PODCAST "SERIAL" AND A
SUBJECT HBO SERIES.
A BALTIMORE JUDGE APPROVED A
MOTION TO VACATE HIS CONFECTION
AND RELEASED HIM TO HOME
DETENTION.
PROSECUTORS HAVE THE CHOICE OF
DROPPING THE CHARGES OR RETRYING
THE CASE.
PROSECUTORS ASKED FOR A NEW
TRIAL CITING NEWLY INTRODUCED
EVIDENCE WHICH REVEALED TWO
OTHER POSSIBLE SUSPECTS.
TO BE CLEAR PROSECUTORS ARE NOT
SAYING THAT SYED IS NOT GUILTY.
INSTEAD THEY'RE SATISFYING THEY
HAVE NO CONFIDENCE IN HIS PAST
CONVICTION AND THAT KEEPING HIM
IN PRISON AS THEY CONTINUE THEIR
INVESTIGATION WOULD BE UNJUST.
ALEXANDRA FIELD IS FOLLOWING
THIS FOR US CLOSELY.
ALEX, TELL US MORE ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENED AT TODAY'S COURT
HEARING.
>> Reporter: LOOK, YOU SAW SOME
OF THAT EMOTION AS HE LEFT THE
COURTHOUSE.
TEARS AND CHEERS GOING UP AS THE
JUDGE DECIDED TO VACATE THE LIFE
SENTENCE AGAINST ADNAN SYED.
HE WAS IN THAT COURTROOM.
THE HEARING LASTING ABOUT TWO
HOURS WITH A 30-MINUTE RECESS IN
BETWEEN.
THIS WAS A TIME WHERE THE
PROSECUTORS WERE ABLE TO LAY OUT
THE EVIDENCE THEY HAD PRESENTED
IN THEIR MOTION.
EVIDENCE THAT WAS GLEANED FROM A
YEAR-LONG REINVESTIGATION INTO
THE CASE THAT REALLY DID FOCUS
ON THIS NEWLY DEVELOPED
INFORMATION ABOUT TWO
ALTERNATIVE SUSPECTS AND ALSO A
FAILURE OF THE STATE AS TOLD BY
THE PROSECUTORS TO SHARE SOME OF
THAT EXISTING INFORMATION ABOUT
TWO ALTERNATIVE SUSPECTS WITH
THE DEFENSE AT THE TIME OF THE
TRIAL.
THAT ARGUMENT SEEMINGLY ENOUGH
TO SWAY THE JUDGE TO VACATE THE
SENTENCE.
DURING THE HEARING WE ALSO DID
HEAR FROM HAMAN LEE'S FAMILY,
HER BROTHER ZOOMING IN TO SPEAK
ON BEHALF OF THE FAMILY,
REMINDING THOSE IN THE COURTROOM
THAT FOR HIM THIS IS NOT A
PODCAST, THIS IS REAL LIFE.
WHILE WE DID HEAR FROM
PROSECUTORS AS SOON AS THE
DECISION TO VACATE THE SENTENCE
WAS HANDED DOWN, WE DID ALSO
HEAR FROM AN ATTORNEY
REPRESENTING THE LEE FAMILY WHO
HAD THIS TO SAY.
THIS FAMILY IS INTERESTED IN THE
PURSUIT OF JUSTICE.
THEY WANT TO KNOW MORE THAN
ANYBODY WHO IT WAS THAT KILLED
HAMAN LEE.
JAKE.
>> SO THE PROSECUTORS ARE
WAITING TO DECIDE WHETHER THEY
WILL DROP THE CHARGES ONCE THEY
GET THE RESULTS FROM THE D NCHT
A CASE.
WHAT DO WE KNOW ABOUT THAT?
>> THEY ARE MAKING IT VERY CLEAR
THIS IS NOT A DECLARATION OF
THEIR BELIEF IN HIS INNOCENCE.
THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY TO MOVE
FORWARD WITH THE INVESTIGATION.
THEY WANT TO ENSURE THAT JUSTICE
IS BEING SERVED, THAT THERE'S
ADEQUATE REPRESENTATION FOR
ADNAN SYED SHOULD THERE BE A
FUTURE TRIAL.
THEY SAY THAT A DECISION TO GO
TO TRIAL WILL NOW HINGE ON
PENDING DNA RESULTS.
THEY'RE DOING TOUCH TESTING FOR
DNA.
THIS IS A TYPE OF TESTING THAT
WAS NOT AVAILABLE AT THE TIME
THAT SYED WAS CONVICTED SO
THEY'RE TRYING TO EXPEDITE THE
RESULTS AND SEE WHAT THEY CAN
GLEAN FROM THOSE RESULTS BEFORE
DECIDING WHETHER TO GO FORWARD
WITH A NEW TRIAL OR DISMISS
CHARGES ALTOGETHER.
>> WE SAW ADNAN SYED LEAVING
WITH AN ANKLE MONITOR.
WHAT'S NEXT FOR HIM?
>> HE WILL BE UNDER AT HOME
MONITORING BUT REALLY YOU CAN'T
UNDERESTIMATE OR UNDERPLAY THE
ENORMITY OF THIS DECISION.
LOOK, THE DEFENSE HAS WORKED FOR
MORE THAN TWO DECADES TO TRY TO
APPEAL THIS CONVICTION.
ADNAN SYED HAS FOR YEARS AND
YEARS MAINTAINED HIS INNOCENCE
IN THE MURDER OF HIS
EX-GIRLFRIEND.
THIS IS A DAY THAT CAME, WE HAVE
TO REMIND OURSELVES, NOT JUST
BECAUSE OF THE DEFENSE'S EFFORTS
TO CLEAR HIM OR EXONERATE HIM,
IT IS SOMETHING THAT CAME
BECAUSE THE PROSECUTION WAS PART
OF T